>> Greg: RIGHT NOW THAT IS THE
UKRAINE REFRAIN.
>> ANOTHER DAY, ANOTHER SMOKING
GUN.
>> IT IS DEFINITELY A SMOKING
>> IT WAS A SMOKING GUN.
>> IT WAS A REVEALED.
>> CAME OUT TO DEFEND THE
INITIAL BOND CHILD.
>> OBVIOUSLY YET ANOTHER
CLINICAL BOMBSHELL.
>> AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> Greg: IT'S LIKE THEY HAVE
THE SAME SCRIPT.
IT'S SAD TO HEAR THE SAME MEDIA
SHAKES WITH RAGE OVER A PHONE
CALL THAT CAME WITH THE
TRANSCRIPTS.
AND THEN THERE SYRIA.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS ABANDONING
THE KURDS.
>> SELLING OUT THE KURDS.
WE ARE NOW BANNED ABANDONING THE
KURDS.
>> ABANDONING OUR ALLIES.
>> ITS ABANDONMENT.
>> ABANDONMENT OF KURDISH
ALLIES.
>> IF WE ARE BACKING AWAY FROM
OUR COMMITMENT TO THE KURDS,
WHERE DID THEY TURN?
>> Greg: THAT WAS ALARMINGLY
IDENTICAL.
SO THOSE WHO FEAR THIS PRESIDENT
WOULD LEAD US INTO WAR HAVE
TURNED NOW HE'S MOVING TROOPS.
JUST LIKE THE PEOPLE WHO HATED
JOHN BOLTON BUT THEN WERE
OUTRAGED WHEN HE BOLTED BECAUSE
TRUMP WASN'T HOCKESSIN ENOUGH.
OF COURSE WE KNOW TRUMPS A
DOUBT.
HE FACES VARIOUS TRADE WARS OVER
A REAL ONE AND DELIGHTED IN
MOVING NORTH KOREA'S REASONS FOR
PARANOIA.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE TRUMP HAS A
CONSISTENT IF NOT ALWAYS ARTFUL
POINT OF VIEW.
>> WE ARE GETTING OUT OF THE
ENDLESS WARS.
IT'S LIKE QUAGMIRE.
WE ARE UP TO CLOSE TO
$8 TRILLION AND WE ARE BRINGING
OUR FOLKS BACK HOME.
TO GO WE ARE NOT ACTING AS
POLICE.
WE ARE POLICING AREAS, WE ARE
DOING JOBS THAT OTHER COUNTRIES
SHOULD BE DOING.
>> THE HARDEST THING I HAVE TO
DO BY FAR, MUCH HARDER THAN THE
WITCH HUNT.
IT'S SIGNING LETTERS TO PARENTS
OF SOLDIERS THAT HAVE BEEN
KILLED THAT WENT TO WAR AND I
GAVE OUT FIVE PURPLE HEARTS TO
INCREDIBLE YOUNG MEN.
FOR ME, IT'S VERY HARD WHEN I
SEE THAT.
IT'S VERY HARD.
>> STRONG WORDS WHICH IS WHY THE
MEDIA DIDN'T TOUCH IT.
WHETHER YOU HATE IT OR NOT,
TRUMP'S DECISION WAS AN
IMPULSIVE BUT ACTUALLY I
CAMPAIGN PROMISE.
HE IS A MISER WITH BLOOD AND
TREASURE.
YOU CAN CALL IT MISGUIDED BUT AT
LEAST ADMIT IT EXISTS.
THE MEDIA WON'T.
IT'S REPETITION 24 SEVENTHS TO
AVOID REAL TRUTH ABOUT A NEW ER
ERA.
PUNISHMENT OF CHINA FOR
OPPRESSING MUSLIMS, CONTINUED
PRISON REFORM, RECORD EMPLOYMENT
FOR WOMEN AND MINORITIES, AND
OUTCOME ATTEMPTS TO DRAW DOWN
FOREIGN WARS.
THAT THE MEDIA FIND SUCH THINGS
TRIVIAL SAYS IT ALL ABOUT THE
MEDIA.
IT'S NOT HAWKS VERSUS DUDS, IT'S
THEM VERSUS YOU.
THEY CAN'T STAND YOU AND I GOT
THE DEAL IS MUTUAL.
I'M NOT GOING TO ADMIT TO BEING
AN EXPERT ON SYRIA BUT IT'S VERY
SUSPICIOUS HOW THE LINE WAS
DRAWN KNOW IMMEDIATELY THAT
EVERYBODY HAD THE EXACT SAME
THING BEFORE THE DUST SETTLED.
>> Dana: I THINK PARTLY THAT'S
BECAUSE THEY WERE HEARING THAT
DIRECTLY FROM PEOPLE WHO WERE
THERE ON THE GROUND WHO ARE IN
OUR INTELLIGENCE AND IN MILITARY
FORCES.
>> Greg: BUT NOBODY MENTIONS A
NUMBER OF TROOPS.
YOU HAVE TO LIKE PULL THAT OUT
OF PEOPLE.
EITHER YOU JUST MENTIONED IT --
I'M PRETTY CLEAR.
WE HAD 100 TO 150 PEOPLE THERE
AND THEY WERE HELPED TO DETER
THE SITUATION.
COMMANDERS IN CHIEF HAD TO MAKE
REALLY TOUGH DECISIONS AND
NOTHING IS BLACK-AND-WHITE.
THERE IS TWO SHADES OF GRAY AND
IT'S ALWAYS COMPLEX AND THE
KURDS SHOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT WE
WERE THERE AND IT WAS
TRANSACTIONAL AND IT WAS
TACTICAL AND IT WAS TEMPORARY.
HOWEVER, ANY PRESIDENT KNOWS
THAT NOT ALL DECISIONS ARE GOING
TO BE AGREED BY WITH EVERYBODY
ELSE BUT THE DECISION-MAKING
PROCESS SHOULD BE ONE THAT CAN
BE RESPECTED AND IN THIS CASE IT
WAS VERY HARD TO UNDERSTAND HOW
IT HAPPENED ALL OF A SUDDEN AND
NOW HE'S TALKING ABOUT
MEDIATION.
HE JUST SAID IN A PRESS
CONFERENCE WILL NOW WE ARE MAYBE
GOING TO MEDIATE BUT THEY
LOST --
THE KURDS, LOST 100 PEOPLE LAST
NIGHT IN THE FIGHTING SO I THINK
THAT THE CRITIC OF THE PRESIDENT
ON THE RIGHT, THEY HAVE HIS BEST
INTEREST AND RIGHT.
THEY DON'T WANT HIM TO BE
CRITICIZED WHERE THEY WANT HIM
TO BE ABLE TO DO WHAT HE NEEDS
TO DO TO FULFILL CAMPAIGN
PROMISES AND TO DO WHAT HE --
WE DEFEATED ISIS.
WE HAD VERY FEW PEOPLE THERE.
THE KURDS WERE ACTUALLY ON THE
GROUND DOING THE WORK FOR US AND
THEY LOST 11,000 PEOPLE AND THE
KURDISH LEADERS, THEY ALSO HAD
TO SEND LETTERS TO THEIR PEOPLE.
>> Greg: SO WHEN DO YOU PULL
OUT?
DO YOU EVER PULL OUT JESSE?
THIS IS A MARRIAGE OF
CONVENIENCE BETWEEN AMERICA AND
THE KURDS.
THE KURDS HAVE A LONG-STANDING
FEUD WITH THE TURKS.
DO WE JUST STAY THERE AND END UP
PERHAPS FIGHTING THE TURKS.
>> Jesse: I THINK WHEN
BARACK OBAMA PULLED OUT OF IRAQ,
HE HAD VENTED OUR ALLIES BUT THE
MEDIA HAS SAID THAT WAS A
STRATEGIC REDEPLOYMENT AND THEN
THEY CHEERED HIM AND TRUMP HAD
TO COME IN AND CLEAN IT UP AND
BOMBED EVERYBODY AND PROMISED
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HE WASN'T
GOING TO STAY.
HE'S TRYING TO KEEP A CAMPAIGN
PROMISE.
I AGREE WITH DANA.
WE ARE ALLIED WITH SADDAM
HUSSEIN FOR SHAKING HIS HAND AND
NEXT THING YOU KNOW WE ARE
INVADING THE COUNTRY.
AND THEN COME ON, WE PULLED OUT
AND LEFT THE PEOPLE TO DIE AND
WENT BACK IN AND SAVE THE PEOPLE
AGAIN.
THIS HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
RIGHT NOW TO SAY THAT WE ABANDON
THE KURDS I THINK IT IS NOT
REALLY SAYING WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED.
WE LET THE KURDS HAVE A THIRD OF
SYRIA.
THEY HAD THE ENTIRE NORTHEAST OF
SYRIA WERE 90% OF THE OIL
RESERVES ARE AND ALL OF THE
GREAT AGRICULTURAL LAND.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A VERY
SMALL SECTION RIGHT NOW AND IT'S
RIGHT IN BETWEEN THE PIPELINE
THAT RUNS NORTH OF TURKEY TO
SELL OIL TO THE EUROPEANS.
TURKISH PEOPLE JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THEY HAVE THE PIPELINE
LAUNCH DOWN.
ALL I CARE ABOUT IS THAT WE HAVE
THE ISIS FIGHTERS GUARDED IN THE
PRISONS AND THAT'S ALL I CARE
ABOUT AND IF I WAS THE
PRESIDENT, I WOULD JUST SHIP
THEM ALL TO ANTARCTICA BUT
THAT'S WHY I'M NOT PRESIDENT.
>> Dana:
>> Kana:
>> Kata:
>> Katie: THE QUESTION IS HOW
ARE THEY GOING TO GET IN AND
MAKE SURE THAT THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF ISIS FIGHTERS ARE
JUST GOING TO WALK RIGHT OUT AS
THE PRESIDENT SAID AND GO TO
YEARS.
THAT IS A CONCERN AND ISIS
FIGHTERS GOING TO EUROPE IS A
DIRECT THREAT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE PAID WE JUST INDICTED AND
NICEST GUY A MONTH AGO WHO WENT
TO SYRIA, TRAINED AS A SNIPER,
AND CAME BACK AND WAS LIVING IN
BROOKLYN PLANNING ADDITIONAL TAX
IN THE UNITED STATES SO THESE
ALLIANCES DON'T LAST FOREVER.
THAT IS TRUE.
THE ALLIANCE WITH TURKEY AS A
MEMBER OF NATO HAS TO BE LOOKED
AT BECAUSE TURKEY PRO TOLD THE
PRESIDENT THEY WOULDN'T BE
BOMBING CIVILIANS AND THEY'VE
ALREADY KILLED CIVILIANS IN THE
LAST DAY.
THEY SAID THAT ONE GO AFTER THE
KURDS, THEY ARE DOING THAT.
THEY ARE BOMBING HOSPITALS.
THEY AREN'T HOLDING UP THEIR END
OF THE DEALS WENT JUST A LITTLE
BIT CONFUSED BY THE PRESIDENT'S
STATEMENT THAT HE WANTS TO TAKE
TROOPS OUT, WHICH IS FINE, THAT
SOMETHING HE SAID HE WOULD DO,
CONSISTENT, BUT IT'S
INCONSISTENT WITH WHAT HE JUST
TWEETED WHICH WAS WELL IF THE
KURDS ARE GETTING SLAUGHTERED BY
THE TURKS THAN WE CAN USE
MILITARY OPTION AND SEND
THOUSANDS OF TROOPS AN END IF
YOU'RE OF THE IDEA THAT YOU DO
NOT WANT AMERICAN FORCES TO BE
DEPLOYED ON THE GROUND, YOU HAVE
TO HAVE TO HAVE ALLIANCES ON THE
GROUND AND IF THE TURKS DID
SOMETHING BUT THE KURDS DID MORE
WHEN IT CAME TO FIGHTING ISIS
AND I THINK 11,000 DEAD KURDISH
FIGHTERS IN TERMS OF HOW SMALL
THE POPULATION IS AND GIVING
THEM THE LAND THAT THEY WERE
OCCUPYING IS A PRETTY GOOD DEAL
CONSIDERING WHAT THEY DID FOR US
AND LIMITING THE ATTACKS THAT
HAPPENED ON THE AMERICAN SOIL.
>> Juan: LET ME JUMP IN AND
SAY THAT I JUST DISAGREE WITH
THE PREMISE BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK THIS IS THE MEDIA VERSUS
TRUMP ON THIS ISSUE.
I THINK WE ARE HEARING RIGHT
HERE AT THIS TABLE PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT MEMBERS OF THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA --
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, SAYING THINGS
THAT ARE VERY SMART AND IN
OPPOSITION TO THE PRESIDENT'S
POLICY AND I ALSO THINK
THEREFORE IT'S MUCH MORE THE
CASE THAT YOU SEE PEOPLE, EVEN
PAT ROBERTSON --
I'M JUST CITING PAT ROBERTSON
FOR SAYING THAT TROND IS IN
DANGER OF LOSING HIS MANDATE OF
HEAVEN AS HE PERMITS THE
SLAUGHTER OF THE KURDS AND SO
WHAT YOU SEE AS REPUBLICANS,
INCLUDING LINDSEY GRAHAM, ON
CAPITOL HILL, A FRONT OF THE
PRESIDENT, SAYING THIS IS WRONG,
THIS IS NOT GOOD, AND USING THE
WORD THAT YOU SAY IS SO BAD.
ABANDONMENT.
THEY ARE USING THE SAME WORD.
TO MY MIND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
NOT A MATTER, AGAIN, OF SOME
KIND OF PARTISANSHIP, THIS IS
ABOUT A POLICY DECISION THAT
PEOPLE FIND OBJECTIONABLE.
YOU SAID IT'S ONLY A FEW PEOPLE
BEING MOVED BELGRADE, THE REASON
IT'S A BIG DEAL IS IF TURKEY HAD
ATTACKED AN AMERICAN OR KILLED
AN AMERICAN WE WOULD GO TO WAR
SO WE MOVE OUR PEOPLE --
ALLOW ME TO FINISH.
WE MOVE OUR FORCES OUT OF THE
WAY WHICH ESSENTIALLY GIVES THE
TURKISH AN OPPORTUNITY TO GO
AFTER THE KURDS.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> Katie: I JUST THINK THE
QUESTION ABOUT TURKEY IS WHETHER
THEY BELONG IN NATO, THERE
SHOULD BE SERIOUS CONSIDERATION